sarah who do you think is the most you
know
most likely to trip well i don't know i
i i guess i would agree that you know
what
i think we all have really clumsy i'm
honestly just it's popped in my mind
when when busy hit renee
in the face with the salad bowl what
yeah wait what'd you do
oh my god i almost forgot we had a
shooting scene
yeah we were shooting a scene in a
closet
and uh there was a gag where she was
supposed to you know
spill toss the salad as it were and uh
the next thing i know i was like god
oh my gosh okay so then that
of me talking like this is still in it
but what it does is like renee keeps
asking us
like you guys is a bad is it bad and
it's like her lip is
like four times the size and we're just
like oh it's fine it looks great
normal no no just keep acting you can't
know yeah and i walked in after the
whole thing happened and it was a very
weird energy on the set everyone was
whispering
she had a giant bag of ice on her face
and busy was kind of pacing around
see this is what i imagine girl groups
are like
it was very funny i know you can't laugh
until later but then you laugh
hysterically
you've been holding it for a minute
because you wanted to laugh before yep
i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever